a Sunday night residential fire had many
neighbors really concerned for their
safety well they say crime at the
Fremont Urban Lofts is just getting out
of control and there
is for that recent fire now that complex
is located on Fremont Street right near
Eastern and today neighbors are speaking
out they're asking for help Christian
kosaris with the story
there were Flames coming out of the
Skylight it was already a full Blaze
several residential units destroyed by
recent fires and many others damaged
debris scattered across this apartment
complex but that is the least of David
ostrom's worries and since the first
fire which was four and a half months
ago it's been just a nightmare to live
here it's like a war zone
since that June complex fire were 10
units and more than two dozen cars were
destroyed residents living at Fremont
Urban Lofts near Fremont and Eastern say
the crime has escalated Ostrom sharing
this security video from his backyard
showing someone on his property minutes
before this dumpster fire happened
there's zero security here now so it's
not stopping individuals from being able
to freely come right across the wall and
write into our community Isaiah
Gatherings lives a few units away from
the damaged homes he and several
residents claim something needs to be
done to improve their safety we need
something better we need some some
Outreach we need some help some some
individuals too at the very least help
us with security measures
on Monday pieces of the damaged
structures were dangling from the roofs
by the wind boarded up properties and
broken windows Ostrom says is not
acceptable we reached out to the city of
Las Vegas and they said they are looking
into the matter for now these residents
hope something can be done before more
squatters come in seeking Shelter From
the Colder Weather do you feel safe here
absolutely not no I the only reason I
stay here is because right now we have
nowhere to go
so 8 news now reached out to the Fremont
Urban Lofts office along with the HOA
but we did not get a response we'll keep
you posted on this case